things are not as they seem  sometimes  against my blows  pick up  were created when a necrotic plague  spread  through ketchup and centuries ago the  infected washed in terror as their flesh  black and then died  the strongest medicines could not stop  the decay  eventually they fell into a dormant  state and their bodies were piled up in  dark and forgotten places  where they could rest undisturbed  more fury  adria should be up here  tell us about the black soul stone we  know of the tree that the haradram used  to draft the primeval  what is the purpose of this one your  master file has  good reason to fear it  leave her alone  seize them  my daughter know who i am my darling  i've watched over you all it's not safe  here  i'm surprised cain never told you why i  left he knew i was called to fight the  lords of hell  and i knew he's gone then it's fate that  we have been reunited  according to the haradric texts only two  evils remain  belial is here